-Mon invitée a eu
une carrière dans le privé
après avoir grandi dans une ZEP
de Seine-Saint-Denis,
élevée par des parents immigrés.
Un événement inattendu
est venu bouleverser sa vie,
et l'engagement politique
est alors devenu
une évidence pour elle.
Générique
...
Bonjour,
Prisca Thevenot.
-Bonjour.
-Le public vous a découverte
au mois de janvier 2020,
quand vous avez été nommée
porte-parole d'En Marche.
Depuis, une grande partie
de votre travail politique
consiste en ça.
Là, vous nous parliez
de la réforme des retraites.
*-Laissez-moi vous expliquer.
Oui, nous devons revaloriser
les pensions minimales de retraite,
prendre en compte
les pénibilités,
et les carrières longues.
Moi, je vous dis simplement
qu'il faut augmenter l'âge de départ
pour financer cela.
*-J'ai bien compris...
*-Dites-le à vos camarades.
-C'est un parfait exemple.
Vous passez une grande partie
de votre temps
à défendre l'action
de la majorité, à l'Assemblée,
sur les plateaux télé.
On vous voit ici
face à Jean-Philippe Tanguy.
Vous vous laissez pas déstabiliser,
et pourtant, j'ai lu
que vous vous définissiez
comme timide et sensible.
On peut être porte-parole
et être timide et sensible ?
-Oui,
je pense qu'on peut l'être.
En tout cas, je le suis,
donc je vais pas me réinventer.
Je suis profondément timide
et très émotive.
-Mais donc,
c'est une souffrance pour vous
de faire un plateau télé ?
-Ca pourrait,
mais c'est devenu une force.
Ma timidité m'oblige
à préparer mes sujets.
Ca ne veut pas dire
juste relire des fiches,
mais aussi aller confronter
ces sujets avec mon entourage.
Ma famille proche,
évidemment, tout d'abord,
mais également
les gens de mon quotidien :
le boulanger, la boulangère,
mais aussi les professeurs,
les parents d'élèves que je croise.
-Vous forcez votre nature ?
Vous devenez une autre personne ?
-Je ne suis pas
une autre Prisca Thevenot.
Je m'oblige à me dépasser,
à me surpasser
et je pense
que c'est comme ça qu'on avance,
c'est-à-dire ne pas rester
sur nos acquis, sur nos facilités,
et quelque part,
on apprend tout au long de la vie.
Il faut qu'on s'en souvienne,
en tant que politique.
-Quand vous devenez porte-parole,
vous êtes militante En Marche.
Vous n'avez aucun mandat,
vous n'êtes pas députée, pas élue.
Comment ça marche ?
Porte-parole,
propulsée sur les plateaux...
Vous avez eu une formation ?
-Non, non, pas du tout.
Je dois le dire, je me permets,
je suis toujours
une simple militante.
J'ai juste une mission particulière.
-Vous avez un peu plus de bouteille.
Vous êtes habituée à débattre.
Vous ne l'aviez jamais fait, avant.
-Non. Par contre, débattre,
on le fait
depuis le plus jeune âge.
Nos enfants essayent de débattre
pour nous convaincre.
Je le fais maintenant
de façon plus officielle,
plus affirmée,
et devant plus de personnes.
Il n'y a pas de formation,
et la meilleure expérience qui soit,
c'est la vie.
C'est d'être en capacité
de se dire
qu'on ne sait pas tout
et qu'on va apprendre,
pas tout seuls,
mais avec les autres,
et pas seulement
celles et ceux
qui pensent comme nous,
mais surtout
ceux qui ne pensent pas comme nous.
C'est peut-être la meilleure école
de la formation.
-Alors, pendant longtemps,
vous étiez loin
de la politique.
Vous avez eu une carrière
comme consultante dans les télécoms.
Et puis, un jour, est arrivé
ce que vous espériez
sans plus y croire :
vous êtes devenue maman.
-Oui.
Oui, c'est vrai,
en réalité...
Merci pour le portrait
que vous dressez,
mais en réalité,
j'ai eu un parcours
d'une banalité extraordinaire,
et c'est peut-être ça
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui,
je suis une députée pas ordinaire,
parce que j'attache
une grande importance à ma famille,
bien évidemment mes enfants,
mes deux garçons,
que je ne cache pas,
qu'on voit assez souvent,
mais aussi mes parents,
mes parents qui m'ont appris
la chose la plus importante,
c'est qu'on pouvait tout perdre,
on pouvait tout nous enlever,
sauf une chose cruciale :
l'éducation.
Ma mère, ça a été
l'éducation par les livres.
-Vos parents qui sont nés...
-A l'île Maurice,
et qui sont venus en France
par amour de la France,
qui ont vécu cet amour.
Ma mère, c'est par l'éducation,
par les livres.
Elle prenait des heures carrées
à prendre du temps
avec mes devoirs,
apprendre mes leçons.
C'était vraiment une chance.
Mon père, c'était pas
par les livres, mais par la vie.
Il travaillait de nuit.
J'attendais qu'il rentre.
Quand il rentrait,
vers 3 ou 4h du matin,
j'arrivais discrètement
dans la cuisine
et je le voyais
avec tous les journaux.
Il disait : "C'est bien d'apprendre
ce que les gens ont fait
"dans les livres, mais intéresse-toi
à ceux d'aujourd'hui,
"ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui
pour nous, demain."
C'est important.
-Vous parlez
de la famille qui fait partie
de votre engagement de députée.
-Oui.
-Moi,
si je me suis arrêté
sur vos enfants,
c'est parce que vous avez dit :
"Je me suis lancée
"dans la politique pour changer
"le monde dans lequel
mes enfants allaient grandir."
La naissance de vos enfants
a été le déclic ?
-Exactement. Exactement.
-Et pourquoi ?
Ca a changé
votre vue du monde ?
-Ca m'a obligée.
Je vous parlais de mes parents
car ça s'inscrit
dans cette démarche,
celle de continuer à évoluer
et celle de s'inscrire dans le monde
dans lequel on est.
Il s'avère,
et j'en parle très rarement,
que, pendant longtemps,
pendant mon adolescence,
on m'a dit que,
pour différentes raisons médicales,
je ne pourrais pas avoir d'enfants,
Je me suis attachée
à vivre mon existence
pour mon entourage, mais sans penser
à ce que je laisserais,
peut-être égoïstement,
mais le jour où j'ai eu la chance
de tomber enceinte,
d'avoir mes deux enfants,
je me suis dit qu'il fallait
que je m'engage,
et c'est là,
effectivement,
que je me suis arrêtée
de travailler.
Ca ne se fait pas comme ça,
mais grâce à un homme, mon mari,
qui m'a toujours soutenue.
-Vous arrêtez votre carrière,
vous créez une association
pour aider
les mamans qui reprennent
le travail.
L'engagement politique arrive
plus tard, en 2017,
avec une rencontre décisive,
le 30 mars 2017,
à Saint-Denis.
*-Alors, je vais vous parler,
pour être originale,
d'éducation et d'accès
au marché du travail,
mais en se mettant dans les baskets
d'un jeune du 93.
Pourquoi j'estime être légitime
pour parler de ça ?
Je suis fille d'immigrés.
J'ai été élevée dans le 93.
J'ai fait ma scolarité en ZEP.
A Stains, plus précisément.
Avec ce profil, je vous laisse
imaginer les difficultés...
-On parlait de votre timidité,
je suis désolé,
mais il faut du culot
pour prendre la parole
devant un candidat
à la présidentielle.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est joué,
pour vous, ce jour-là ?
-Ce qui s'est joué,
ce jour-là, en réalité,
je ne devais pas être là.
-Pourquoi ?
-J'avais entendu parler
de cette organisation,
pour "les jeunes talents
des quartiers".
Je ne vivais plus dans le 93,
mais je suis une enfant du 93.
Par hasard,
on m'a dit d'aller écouter,
que c'était l'occasion
d'assister à une réunion,
c'était un peu le format
"grand débat", déjà.
C'était en 2017.
J'entendais les uns
passer après les autres,
puis d'un coup,
j'ai voulu lui demander
pourquoi lui,
on devait le croire.
-Et sa réponse vous a convaincue,
et vous vous êtes portée candidate
aux législatives dès 2017.
A l'époque,
vous avez été battue,
mais vous êtes restée engagée
dans En Marche
de façon bénévole.
En plus,
vous avez créé Civil Impact.
Expliquez-nous un peu
ce que c'est.
-Civil Impact,
je suis partie du principe
que j'arrivais
de plein fouet
dans un monde
qui n'était pas le mien,
la politique,
où il y a des codes.
Ces codes, si on veut un peu
les briser, les renverser,
ce qui est un peu mon objet,
il faut quand même les connaître.
-Avant de s'en affranchir ?
-Bien sûr, c'est la base.
Le principe, c'était de se dire
que si je partais de ce postulat,
d'autres aussi.
C'est faux de dire
qu'on va en politique
comme on rentre au McDonald's,
excusez-moi de la comparaison.
Il faut pouvoir s'engager
et créer cette communauté
à laquelle on peut appartenir.
Sur ce principe,
il y a un exemple
qui est très bon en ce moment
et qui, moi,
me guide depuis un certain nombre
d'années, maintenant,
c'est la Première ministre
de Nouvelle-Zélande,
Jacinda Ardern...
-Qui a décidé de se retirer.
-Oui, mais avant,
elle a décidé de s'engager,
et ce d'une façon très étonnante,
c'est-à-dire
qu'elle n'a qu'une seule règle,
celle d'en finir
avec les règles du monde politique,
d'en finir
avec cette vision de la politique
qui veut qu'on soit tout-puissant,
qu'on soit en train
de montrer les muscles,
pour être dans un bras de fer
contre tout, sur tout
et en permanence.
Quelque part, elle assume
qu'il y a peut-être une faiblesse,
la plus belle,
que nous devons mettre au centre
de notre action politique,
celle du coeur,
qui nous permet d'avoir
une action raisonnée,
passionnée, mais surtout audible
et qui embarque.
Elle nous rappelle
ce que j'explique
dans Civil Impact,
mon école d'engagement,
c'est que, finalement,
on ne doit pas être attaché
au pouvoir en tant que politique,
on doit être attaché
à notre devoir,
de faire, de bien faire,
pas pour nous,
mais pour celles et ceux
qui nous ont donné une mission.
-Derrière l'école,
il y a l'idée que vous voulez faire
bénéficier d'autres jeunes,
peut-être issus
du même milieu que vous,
confrontés aux mêmes obstacles,
de votre expérience ?
-Il s'agit simplement de dire :
"Venez. Venez apprendre.
"Il est faux de dire
que l'engagement est facile
"et qu'il est inné.
"L'engagement est difficile
et il s'apprend."
-Justement,
l'engagement est difficile.
Je me suis arrêté
sur cette phrase.
L'engagement peut être vécu
comme une souffrance ?
-C'est dur.
-Dur en quoi ?
-Je crois que j'invente rien.
Je ne surprendrais pas grand monde
en disant que oui,
c'est dur, c'est compliqué,
parfois très complexe,
surtout en tant que mère de famille,
vue comme "un peu jeune".
Est-ce insurmontable ?
Non, à la condition
qu'on accepte de ne pas être seul,
qu'on accepte de tendre la main,
pour aider les autres
et pour demander de l'aide.
-C'est l'heure de notre quiz.
Je vais prononcer le début
d'une phrase, ce sera à vous
de la compléter.
"Etre une femme députée,
c'est plutôt..."
-C'est plutôt complexe.
C'est ce que je disais avant.
En plus d'être une femme députée,
je suis une maman députée,
donc, c'est rock'n'roll,
souvent,
c'est passionnant, toujours.
C'est une force.
-Vous voulez dire
que le regard des hommes
sur les femmes,
en politique,
pose problème ?
-C'est le regard
du monde politique
sur les femmes politiques.
-Les femmes aussi ?
-Bien sûr. Vous savez,
je ne suis pas de celles qui disent
que les femmes sont, par défaut,
dans une sororité absolue.
Ce n'est pas vrai.
On doit le dire aussi.
Nous sommes bienveillantes, oui,
mais il faut aussi affirmer
qu'il y a beaucoup de femmes,
pour exister dans ce monde,
qui ont dû faire comme les hommes.
On reproduit certains schémas.
-On poursuit notre quiz.
"Depuis que je suis députée,
"ma famille me dit souvent..."
-"Mange mieux."
-Ah ?
Ils se préoccupent
de votre santé ?
Et vos absences ?
-Ils ne se plaignent pas,
parce que...
Déjà, avant,
dans le privé,
je n'étais pas souvent présente,
mais c'est vrai
que je fais attention
à avoir des moments un peu sacrés,
où je pose mon téléphone
et je suis là.
Oui, on a des rythmes infernaux
et je mange quand je peux,
et ce que je trouve.
Ce n'est pas très bien.
-"Entre porte-parole,
on se dit souvent..."
-"Ecoute."
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Oui, on est là pour parler,
pour expliquer,
pour mieux appréhender
certains débats
sur la sphère médiatique,
mais il faut
qu'on apprenne à écouter.
-Une dernière question.
Vous êtes passionnée
par la politique.
Pour vous,
cet engagement est pour la vie
ou temporaire ?
-On ne sait pas
de quoi demain sera fait.
-Vous vous projetez ?
-Je me projette
le plus loin possible,
en tant que femme et mère,
ensuite, l'avenir le dira.
J'ai été salariée,
je suis en politique,
je n'étais pas censée être mère,
je le suis.
On verra.
-Merci, Prisca Thevenot,
d'être venue vous confier.
-Merci.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...